can't hide your any pizza I'm sorry I  missed that whole thing little parties  from cool Joey let's wait to see if  it'll start  will you rotate your axis it's not good  for your digestion to eat while you  invert it okay dear 400 you come on okay  Marlene honey pass the kill no I don't  want to Oh number off Marlene don't talk  to your father that way  Graham I'm on the phone okay I like some  tea please  look I'm gonna have to call you back  I still think we shouldn't have started  it Gavin Harley pass it damn choppity  hmm why isn't she home yet I'm not sure  where Jennifer is mom sure Melanie hours  ago with our a hard time keeping track  room thank you aren't you and Jennifer  getting along